dopo questo video quanta gente me l'ha
richiesto io abito a torino per chi non
lo sapesse ed è una città fortemente
legata a culti esoterici un sacco di vie
di angoli di anfratti e incredibilmente
anche di tombini possono essere
ricollegati ha qualcosa di magico ed
esoterico e uno dei tanti motivi per cui
amo questa città e oggi vi porterò con
me a distanza di sicurezza di almeno due
metri uno dall'altro in giro per le
strade della torino esoterica
sull'esoterismo di torino ci hanno
scritto libri su libri su libri su libri
quindi in un video di youtube
soprattutto di tir posso fare molto poco
torino geograficamente è la punta di due
triangoli quello della magia bianca con
praga e lione è quello della magia nera
con londra e san francisco
il fatto che abbia questa forte
componente esoterica è data da molti
piccoli fattori il fatto che passi il
45esimo parallelo attraverso di lei fa
in modo che si accumuli della magia
positiva quanto pare si parla del po si
parla della dora insomma si risale a
tempi antichi ma partiamo subito per la
prima location forse anche quella più
centrale di tutte piazza castello
questa piazza è considerata il centro
del centro di torino
perché da essa partono le tre vie
principali via po via garibaldi e via
roma
possiamo trovare il maestoso palazzo
reale dove di solito ci fanno delle
mostre fotografiche poi c'è la
altrettanto bello palazzo madama dove
davanti c'è un monumento all'alfiere
dell'esercito sardo ma noi siete qui per
la parte storica e piazza castello è
considerato l'epicentro di tutta la
magia che c'è a torino il cancello
infatti del palazzo reale divide la
parte bianca della città dalla parte
nera la parte est dalla parte ovest e le
due statue fanno da guardiani non venivo
in centro da 15 anni più o meno
guardando il portone d'ingresso di
palazzo reale e andando a sinistra ci si
ritrova al duomo di torino in cui ha
costruito quel lenzuolino assolutamente
non legato a niente di magico
storicamente esoterico e qui nel duomo
di torino è custodita la sacra sindone
come si vede da questo veramente orrendo
logo una donna che schifo che fa se
invece guardando il portone d'ingresso
di palazzo reale si va a destra sotto i
portici
prima di arrivare alla mole antonelliana
che il nostro prossimo punto di
riferimento prima c'è un altorilievo di
cristoforo colombo
si dice che toccando il mignolo
dell'altorilievo di cristoforo colombo
porti fortuna ed infatti l unica cosa
lucidissima dell'opera comunque andando
giù di lì prendendo via po si arriva
alla mole antonelliana il simbolo dei
simboli torinese si disegna per forza di
cose ovunque nei quadri nei biglietti
del pullman o immaginatevi che nel
sottosuolo di torino ci sia un mare di
energia positiva e come fai per
irradiarla dappertutto con un'antenna la
mole antonelliana e considerata
l'antenna dell'energia positiva di
torino in più è uno dei pochi monumenti
in cui tu non riesci a farti una foto a
fianco
non so magari arrivano i turisti
vogliono vedere l'amore vogliono
mettersi a fianco per tenerla in piedi
noti ma per scherzare come la torre di
pisa e non puoi farlo perché in mezzo a
qualsiasi via pedonale del centro pd the
miz mezzo sdraiare per terra col
grandangolo per riuscire a fare una foto
dove ci si sia tu sia l'intera mole e
con orgoglio posso dire di esserci
riuscito
sono lì sono il proprio lì in mezzo è
come la
continuando per via po si arriva ad una
delle piazze più grande di torino piazza
vittorio veneto e gigantesca e piena di
portici e io la amo
prima di superare il po di arrivare al
prossimo punto esoterico mi prendo una
fettona di torta da clarissa mi godo un
pochino il paesaggio provo a contare i
cadaveri che vedo passare nel po che
ormai è radioattivo supero il ponte e
arrivo alla gran madre questa chiesa e
in un punto molto centrale dopo piazza
vittorio
tanto che qualsiasi fotografia tu faccia
è incredibile ma non è quella la cosa
esoterica della gran madre
le due statue che ci sono ai poli
opposti dell'ingresso che sarebbero una
la fede è una la religione
indicherebbero dove sia sepolto il santo
graal c'è non solo la sindone pure il
gran c'abbiamo qua
roma provincia torino capitale se torino
avesse il mare sarebbe una piccola bari
anche se diceva le avrei voluto
mostrarvi anche l'interno della gran
madre ma purtroppo in quel momento c'era
un funerale
ma questa non è l'unica delle mie
fortune in queste disavventure
ma andando in via xx settembre si può
trovare quello che viene chiamato il
portone del diavolo e la porta appunto
di questo palazzo che ha dei disegni ed
il basso lievi incredibili e il
batacchio che tu usi per entrare a
proprio la testa del diavolo in persona
e si dice che lui abbia costruito questa
porta perché anni anni anni fa uno
stregone decise di evocarlo dc ma mi
sono rotto le balle voglio evocare satar
a tutti i costi
satana che ci aveva altri casi da fare
esce fuori dice beh che cazzo vuoi e lo
stregone di sguardi volevo evocarla per
cazzi miei
e lui dice no mi hai disturbato perfetto
ti chiudo per sempre in questo palazzo e
lo sigillo con questa porta certi
dialoghi non sono proprio quelli
originali però se no ti aspetti una così
imponente una cosa bellissima
sono arrivato io ed era aperta era
aperta con un cardiologo scrittura
dell'ingresso e dall'altra parte è morto
tutto quello che poteva esserci di
magico dall'esperienza però almeno ho
fatto qualche ripresina delle
decorazioni che tra l'altro il portone
del diavolo apre alla banca nazionale
del lavoro
ironico spostandomi poi verso l'ultimo
punto del nostro tour che piazza statuto
mi imbatto nella fontana angelica di
piazza solferino
questa stupenda fontana con quattro
statue che rappresentano l'autunno e
l'inverno la primavera e l'estate si
dice che l'acqua che fuoriesce da questa
fontana sia la fonte di conoscenza degli
uomini in teoria dovrebbe essere una
cosa positiva della magia bianca ma
visto come la gente usa le informazioni
ultimamente poi oltre piazza solferino
continuando a camminare un pochino di
più se arriva a piazza statuto
la piazza della magia nera per
antonomasia non è bellissima visivamente
rispetto alle altre ma una delle statue
più belle secondo me prima di tutto
questa piazza dina associata alla vallo
ciso room era il luogo in cui uccidevano
tutti condannati a morte
anche perché al di sotto c'è una
necropoli e al di sopra di questa
necropoli si erge il monumento ai caduti
lavoratori del frejus
si dice che l'angelo che sta in cima a
questa statua sia lucifero e che lui
abbia il volto girato verso est
perché con la sua armata delle tenebre
sta andando contro allarmata del sole
l'armata della luce e poi ci sono tante
piccole teorie si dice che col dito stia
indicando un luogo specifico di torino e
poi con il piede stia indicando
sottosuolo quindi l'inferno non ne
usciamo vivi vi consiglio di leggere
qualche libro anche se non abitate in
piemonte on a torino perché veramente
affascinante e purtroppo mi devo fermare
qui anche se ho parlato poco e sembra
che abbia visto poco in realtà il tour è
durato cinque ore di cammino e quindi
insomma vi ho dato delle bricioline e mi
piacerebbe veramente che voi una volta
finito tutto quanto veniste a visitare
torino perché devo dire che ne vale
veramente la pena
lo sguardo magnetico gli serve per i
piloti smo alla scoperta di luoghi
personaggi della torino esoterica